Speaker 1: I got a really great email from
a viewer named Wade who said covid has taken
away our ability to behave.
And I think it goes much further.
There seems to be almost like a covid induced
psychosis that is plaguing this country and
some other parts of the world.
And I want to go through it today.
I already discussed on yesterday's bonus show
that a number of unruly passengers on airplanes
are being reported to the FAA.
That number is increasing dramatically and
much of it is related to where it's triggered
by mask's people angry about someone else
wearing a mask.
People angry about someone else not wearing
a mask, masks and just getting back to being
in close quarters with people on airplanes
is causing many unruly passengers.
We talked about that yesterday, but as Wade
wrote to me, he said, quote, As more and more
people attend events and begin to travel,
there's an increasing level of violence and
frustration that on the surface might seem
to result of not having to practice decorum
and civility in similar situations for the
past year due to the pandemic.
I think there's something to this one category.
Fan behavior at sporting events in Washington,
D.C.
Fans fan runs onto court during Washington
Wizards Game four in latest act of misbehavior,
games just started and there is a rash of
this.
The seventy Sixers, Knicks and Jazz have had
to ban fans following playoff game incidents
involving players.
Then it grew more.
And now five NBA venues have banned fans for
disrespectful behavior during games.
And it's not just happening in basketball
and it's not just happening in the U.S..
In Glasgow, Scotland, fans of the Rangers
football club went nuts, thousands of them
defying covid warnings against large gatherings,
getting together in George Square to celebrate
the Rangers winning their first Scottish Premiership
championship in 10 years.
The square was just strewn with broken bottles
and bags, and there were flares launched and
all sorts of stuff.
Riot police came out.
And then lastly, on the sports front, Marcellus
Razorbacks fans in Arkansas led to a bunch
of arrests and charges.
One such fan pleaded guilty to violating the
face coverings rule.
Then we have all of the airline stuff.
A report from CNBC explaining that a flight
attendant union chief says unruly behavior
from plane passengers has never been this
bad.
We mentioned yesterday that a Southwest Airlines
passenger punched out a flight attendant's
teeth last week, I believe two teeth.
It's actually so bad that American Airlines
is extending their suspension of alcohol service
because they believe the alcohol can be an
aggravating factor.
Yeah, it can.
And then the road rage has just exploded.
Some examples include a rash of road rage
incident in North Carolina, in Los Angeles
and Colorado, in Atlanta.
I don't believe this is as simple as people
have gotten used to not having to behave because
they've been home for a year plus and now
they're around people and they forgot how
to behave.
That just doesn't strike me as the explanation.
Some of this is that there are people who
just no longer care about decorum.
Some are furious about the pandemic and about
shutdowns.
And instead of just being glad to be back
to doing things, they're going nuts and they're
taking their fury out on others.
For other people, there is just the difficulty
of reintegrating after being as many people
were and continue to be so scared to do anything.
And there's a sort of PTSD taking place.
It's coming out in some weird ways for other
people.
I think the becoming unaccustomed to being
in groups has created a sort of agoraphobia
and some people stay home as a result of it.
Others just kind of feel stressed when they
go out.
And then you have people who are reacting
by lashing out in some of these weird ways.
I think this is going to continue for some
time.
We've not even we're only starting to see
the resumption in travel we're seeing.
Oh, but let me mention one other thing.
Commuting is horrible psychologically.
People who have long commutes, it's just a
real drag on quality of life.
We know this from study after study, not having
to commute for so long for many people and
then being dropped back into a commute as
traffic is starting to build again.
I can only imagine that that's having a real
impact on a lot of people's.
Psychological state, it took months to adjust
to what was a new reality during the pandemic.
I think it's going to take at least a few
months to adjust to getting out of it, if
indeed we continue to get out of it and hopefully
we will as vaccination continue.
But I don't think that there's any easy solution
to this.
Let me know what you think and we'll have
more on this on our Instagram, where you can
find us at
The
David Pakman Show.